aujourd'hui pour ce nouvel épisode de
dans son corps nous recevons un invité
extrêmement cool et branché qui vient
nous parler de sa particularité à lui il
s'agit de pierre laporte et il pleut pas
de pantalon et veste de cuir lapin
[Musique]
pierre et photographes vidéastes et
streamer sur twitch il anime la chaîne
le club avec guillem de youtube entre
autres sa lumière salue julien alors
quelle est la particularité physique at
war hallinger ni au pâtis qui s'appelle
la dystrophie musculaire de becker qui
est le petit cousin de la duchesne qui
est malade il est presque les plus
répandues beaucoup plus grave que la
mienne la dystrophie musculaire de
becker est une maladie rare causée par
une anomalie génétique elle ne touche
que les gars sont le plus souvent
pendant l'enfance ou à l'adolescence et
donc du coup c'est une maladie qui
s'attaque donc au muscle qu'avec une
hyper fatigabilité une destruction
musculaire si bas c'est malheureusement
dégénératif je pense qu'une espérance de
vie normale ce normal et après le seul
truc maintenant que je grandisse et de
surveiller le coeur et tout ça mais
sinon c'est souvent les gros muscles les
cuisses les mollets et voilà il faut que
je sois vigilant pas faire trop
d'efforts la myopathie de becker c'est
une dystrophie musculaire c'est à dire
un trouble du développement des muscles
elle entraîne une faiblesse
principalement au niveau des gens mais
aussi au niveau du coeur
comment tu as réagi quand tu t'es rendu
compte que tu avais quelque chose de
différent les autres
mal en fait ça se déclenche un peu tard
je t'ai toujours mal attendu n'est
malade mais ça a déclenché plus tard
pour moi c'était une croissance de 2 à 8
ans et donc là ça commence tout de suite
pas de pierre un peu une feignasse en
sport donc le prof va le dire et tout ça
mais toi tu galères un peu tu te ramener
la pâte tu comprends pas trop pourquoi
donc tu sens quelque chose change est en
toi donc déjà tu lis mal hélas débutent
les premières hospitalisations tu
comprends pas tu te retrouve tout seul
dans sa chambre
et ça commence à être un peu difficile
mais tu le vois tes par un peu désespéré
tout ça et là c'est là où s'enclenche
coup mon parcours hospitalisé je pense
je peut catégoriser de chaotique où donc
donc ça commence moi j'étais en bretagne
donc ça commence alors une en faisant
sécher basique et donc on sait pas trop
où on voit que j'ai aimé celle où j'ai
beaucoup de cp carouge explosé à deux
milieux comme si je fais un infarctus et
tout ça donc on a commencé à pouvoir
faire dts donc là j'ai mes première
biopsie donc on commence à vous ouvrir
un peu le charcuter pour savoir ce que
j'ai là on part sur une glycogène aux
nouveaux là on part là dessus donc voilà
on allait lui manquant donc le sucre
était mal assise mais je suis pas quoi
sachant pas dangereux il s'avance pas du
coup je me renvoie la timone de
marseille on fait des trucs comme ça il
voulait utiliser mon muscle pas pourquoi
au final saint vincent de paul l'avait
perdue qui m'ont réouvert donc nestea
zip forcément général belle souffrance
ça apporte rien c'est un vieux monsieur
et tout ça donc on a un peu d'espérer
donc là je dis ça ça fait déjà trois
quatre ans on l'a dit et après je pars
au siège des hôtels lieux de nantes vous
de découvrir un magnifique professeur
keith et décide après l'auscultation
basique te dire que ma mère aurait
syndrome de munchausen et que je suis
pas vraiment malade et qu'elle ment pas
on est tous à vous comment on peut a
breaké dans la tête la tête de mes
parents je pense je pense qu'il ya
détruit un peu beaucoup de fils adam est
donc tout s'écroule pour moi donc je
passe du statut battait malades et après
je suis plus malade c'est ma mère qui
mon prénom je sais pas enfin du bois et
là c'est là où tout syndrome d'imposture
et tout ce qui va me rendre le plus
malheureux
le plus fin octobre dans la main
c'est là que ça départ donc après il
reste je pas des années où on fait plus
rien parce qu'on est démoralisé jusqu'au
jour où mais mon nom dans un carnet de
rendez vous auquel le professeur arnold
munich qui était un peu l'éminence enfin
qualité m'a même conseillé au
gouvernement à tout ça et bam
on voit western belote basique et au
final j'ai la dystrophie musculaire de
becker et donc voilà donc je pense qu'il
a fallu sept ans sept ans de roller
coaster et le drame de tout ça c'est
qu'à un moment ça développe une espèce
de complaisance avec la douleur plus
j'avais mal et quand j'avais mal c'était
confirme à la sauvette que tu es une
vraie mélodie ouais ça c'est ma terre
est même aujourd'hui je pense j'ai
bientôt trente ans et j'ai peur qu'on
lycéens prend qu au final on sait bien
que tout ça ça qui m'a rendu plus fous
en fait et encore et toujours même si ça
va venir
c'est le côté handicap invisible avec
zéro diagnostic donc papa possibilité de
dire oui je suis vraiment maladroit hier
de sa les maladies se voit pas mais
c'est un peu difficile et puis surtout
que moi donc j'ai connu le fauteuil
roulant et tout ça donc c'est venu lors
de l'adolescence ou l'adolescence temps
pour organiser un peu la frustration
puisque t'es pas typhon du tout le final
ce qui a été déjà casté la merde c'est
de tester les limites mais tu vois tu
sais que tu vas de lever ton fauteuil
roulant puisque battu peut marcher
c'était vraiment une [ __ ] dems que je
vous obligé de voleurs et où les gens
ont des racines arnaque à l'assurance
as tu nous manque un gros mytho mane et
tout ça tout ça ça m'a vraiment aidé
brisé jusqu'au bout quoi parce que tu as
eu sept ans 2
l'errance musical entre telus tt 15 ans
un peu près mais plus loin en fait je
fais pendant ce temps là ton état tu
disais qu'au début
en fait ça a dégénéré parce qu'en fait
je suis pas les symptômes c'est vraiment
des fois donc c'est lié à l'effort est
souvent froid humidité tout ça donc les
muscles ben si je fais un gros effort en
oeuvre des fardeaux boudin fait mes
muscles vous lâchez un peu vite
détruisent donc il essaie tu sais ça va
un peu fort overdrive et du coup à mes
muscles pas je vais avoir des méga
contracture ne plus marcher faire des
espèces de pousser comme isabelle et du
coup tu vois les douleurs les douleurs
des douleurs et c'est pour ça que là
j'ai commencé pour sa d'âge de 13 14 ans
la morphine qui le seul recours à la
douleur que j'ai pu trouver enfin par
des petits type ceux des grandes et
moins chaudes comme ça mais sinon je
suis sous ce qui est dedans depuis
tellement longtemps
d'ailleurs je sais j'en ai un peu marre
de salaire parce que il ya beaucoup trop
de désagréments des pertes d'appétit
pour ce type à sion s'était vu refuser
un futur un junkie et depuis que j'ai 15
ans tu parlais tout à l'heure de ce côté
peur de passer pour une arnaque donc le
gros le regard des autres tu as ta ce
truc particulier deux à la fois tu es en
fauteuil
donc là le regard des gens sur toi
directement mais en même temps tu tu as
aussi le côté où quand et pas en
fauteuil ou quand tu te lèves de ton
fauteuil tu as aussi une autre forme de
regard un peu mais c'est assez des gens
toi c'est pour toi c'est quoi le quai
plus difficile à vivre au niveau du
regard des autres
non ces deux aspects la moins acérées
que dans les deux côtes et à des
attentes différentes
tentés de goûter damas à main là tu peux
plus mais des rentes est en fauteuil
mais on a toujours l'image souhaite
longue vie aux pattes et tout ça alors
que toi tu dis bah non j'étais allé
fumer mes potes je faire de la merde je
peux être séché les cours tout ça mais
tu vas toujours être le monde signe que
pat tu vois vraiment que si tu as des
mauvaises notes avec tes proches du
joueur enfin fois que ça y est c'est
toujours un peu le chouchou tu vois tu
es un peu la mascotte de tout ce qui
t'empêche enfin je vais avoir des
pensées sexuelles le péché des meufs
gelé picoler avec mes potes je veux
vivre autres comme ça et ça et dans les
deux côtés majestic genre à s'amender
fouet puis non mais ce qui est plus
aussi avec le faudrait c'est qu au tout
début que les parents soient un peu con
qui voit un mec en fauteuil roulant
côtés de leurs enfants que je perde tout
un pan de copains d'un coup je me suis
retrouvé très isolée jeu vidéo dans les
deux cas fin dans les postures verticale
ou un truc comme ça je me retrouvais pas
en fait
donc c'est ça qui a été très très dur
mais surtout que je gardais tout pour
moi en fait
et est ce que je regrette mais ouais
j'aurais dû plus en parler tout ça mais
je sais que le terrain [ __ ] de menteur
en fait que je mange tes atouts donc je
voulais juste passer inaperçu mais c'est
un peu chaud avec un fauteuil roulant
qu'est ce qui reste le plus le plus
pénible pour toi aujourd'hui tout ce
parcours ça m'a ruiné mais un point
inimaginable en fait
et enfin judpci côté rapidement ultra
longue et tout ça et là je vous m'en
sors enfin enfin et surtout apprendre à
prendre soin de moi quoi mais surtout
annonce et tout ce parcours là la vision
des gens enfin même si pour moi comment
j'aime quand ça c'est le pire la praille
et douleurs au final fait ça pour moi
c'est sûr mais je pense que c'est un peu
des acouphènes mais physique en fait je
pense d'acouphènes hésité de genre se
dire ah [ __ ] à coucher une bac tu vas
entendre que ça et tu vas finir fou et
si après tu arrives un peu plus demain
ça passe mais après le plus difficile
c'est les nuits où ça te réveilles tu te
réveilles tu es juste fatigué donc juste
entre celle échappatoire c'est que t'as
pas pris encore des médicaments étudie
maintenant je veux dormir ce que j'ai
envie d'aller tu as toujours des moulins
peu mais obligeant il dira que tout se
passe vraiment dans la tête final
ouais le truc qui avec un peu de recul
le truc qui peut-être le plus dur avec
au quotidien
c'est ce à quoi je pouvais juste des
petits détails qui sortent le toit pour
enfin et c'est pas facile puisque comme
le dit mais j'avais cette complaisance
et à la douleur et j'en ai du mal à m'en
détacher tu vas donc j'ai toujours un
côté jean pu non je parle de faire ça
mais vraiment des trucs qu'on dit ah bah
non mais là je vais m'accorder juste
l'une heure de jeu vidéo tout ça
ce faire à bouffer enfin d'essayer de
bien manger trouver tous les trucs un
peu confus et c'est sur ça joue sur des
petits détails mais c'est des mini fric
sorte de la douleur et de la retraite
arsène est où ton corps et tout ça et je
pense aussi penser la communication et
ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai
découvert sur le tard à l'âge et match
comme ça et c'est ce qui m'a manqué
pendant tout mon parcours de santé aussi
le pas communiquer parce que tu as
tellement de pression extérieure
d'attentes
je vois même même tout ce syndrome
d'imposture que j'ai pu et cumin sens
que je vais attisé mais sans leur
structure a par exemple quand tu vas
voir un spécialiste en biologie
je veux le voir une fois tous les ans et
tu as dit souvent tu dis souvent en bas
j'ai un rhume sais pas quand je vais
chez mes seins je vais pas le rémi thuau
donc là tu vas voir de moi de ton année
où tu peux presque pu marcher étaient
pleins tu vas voir le médecin bah tu te
sens bien
au final tu as la pression ou la
pression entre guillemets tu as ta des
parents comme ça qu'ils vont me dire
ouais tu deviens la taille mal ce qu'ils
t'ont vu souffrir donc il veut plus le
voir se faire et toi tu dois tout à un
rendez-vous à dire ah ouais ouais j'ai
j'ai vachement mal avec ça mais je le
ressentais pas physiquement que j'ai
ressenti beaucoup d'atouts s'améliora
[ __ ] je suis un commentaire je ressens
pas que ça et tout ça et moi j'aurais dû
communiquer ça soit en fait nous
simplifier les choses plutôt que moi
ferment dans ce système de mensonges ou
du coup de l'instant tu t'es cru une
espèce de double culpabilité n'est il
pas allé assez mal et de paris assez
bien exactement agrément c'est ça qui
est ça la psychothérapie c'est un truc
qui fait que même dans la psychothérapie
je faisais pas livrées à fond pour ce en
quoi est ce qu'il ya un parcours famille
assez compliqué avec deux temps où j'ai
une marque a tout lâché pour moi
mon père tu dois quitter ampleur qui
type sportif et tout ça dont quatre sont
des deux devant un truc comme ça c'était
vous vois ça vous tuez tous à un tour
avec double quoi donc des gens qui vont
essayer plus de passer à la vanille
d'autres qui vont essayer de mettre de
côté tu vois donc les deux côtés
n'étaient pas bien ça mais tu dois
jongler avec ça et je me suis jamais
retrouvé la main et c'est leïla
psychothérapie on ne finit pas votre
plutôt que d'essayer de reconstruire mon
passé avec des bouts de ses personnels
des soldats de ce qu'on m'a dit là bas
je vais essayer de tracer tous trois y
avait reconstruire ma propre réalité en
fait et d'accepter ce que j'ai été et
d'accepter que nous vivons entièreté
voilà ça c'est sa venue dire qu'à 29 ans
je dois encore dire oui c'est mon jeu
j'aime la sensation que j'ai eue de
western glotte comme externe de mode
qu'ils un peu mon fait là la
cartographie dont les noms ont coup je
suis vraiment malade mais encore des
fois je ne vais pas dans ton parcours
qui soit musicale ou perso tout à
souvenirs de un jour où quelqu'un
rentable dit un truc ou donner un
conseil qui t'a vraiment aidé ma vie
j'étais con ici bas j'ai jamais cherché
à trouver des gens comme moi et c'est ce
qui m'a motivé à faire mon coming bien
pourquoi tu viens parce que peut-être tu
va montrer à d'autres gens voilà je suis
comme vous et moi j'étais toujours bas
gta iv pas bon tu n'es steve duchesne
des gens qui mouraient autour de moi
j'étais pas légitimer et ce comme ça et
donc je me sentais pas représentés nous
j'ai jamais pu communiquer ça et enfin
même toit les associons par jour soit
malade a parmi les malades comme ça donc
j'ai pas mal discuté avec ce mouvement
non plus non vraiment j'ai dû tout faire
tout seul quoi et c'est ça qui est
difficile depuis quand même même pour
les douleurs physiques usage fait ma
petite tambouille
souvent conscience il vraiment très sale
et du coup si toi tu un conseil à donner
à quelqu'un qui est plus ou moins vrai
dans ta situation ce serait quoi
bah de oued d'en parler et au près tous
vraiment comme ça c'est comme ça que tu
trouves un peu ta place et que je fais
le trio aussi parce que du coup annoncé
aux journalistes en vue de satisfaire
tout le monde parce que tu as
l'impression d'en lever quelque chose
aux gens afin qu'ils ont des espaces que
quand est valide c'est dans son qu'ils y
étaient presque les gens vous avez
failli avoir un truc bien et au final
manger un peu arnaques sur la
marchandise et tout mais juste vraiment
communiquer à fond c'est ça le principal
et à se cacher et de s'écouter vraiment
et puis même des fois tu envie de sites
en vue de faire des conneries m'a fait
là tu vois nous on perd à dix fois plus
avec la bk je fais une soirée maton a
pour une semaine tu son tube ouattra
comme un [ __ ] de man show où tu
marcheras plus mais au moins tu profites
tu nous lis mais il faut s'écouter quand
même faudrait vraiment s'écouter
actuellement les traitements avec des
kinés ou des cardiologues ont
principalement pour conséquence de
limiter les conséquences de la
dégénérescence musculaire mais la
recherche notamment dans le domaine des
thérapies géniques donne de bons espoirs
pour l'avenir
ah oui la thérapie génique en gros c'est
maître de l'adn ou de la rn dans les
cellules de quelqu'un pour régler un
problème j'ai géré un espoir quoi
j'espère qu'on voit que les thérapies
géniques avance donc j'espère que pour
l'équipe ça va aller quoi et puis moi
une coûté perso beau lâcher enfin je me
suis senti un peu reconnu ce que j'ai
j'étais dans un protocole mon poursuit
le coeur donc près d'une centaine de
l'hépatite b caire donc ses coûts de me
dire hors ya sans doute sans autres
comme moi ce qui est normal en ce
qu'aujourd'hui un garçon sur 30000 au
chapeau qui se dit mais le livre à une
centaine de gens et du coup je me suis
dit bah moi je fais un truc pourri fente
pour moi donc là on en est une sorte de
personnes non c'était 80 ponts sur les
faits d irm cardiaques et musculaires
pour voir comment ça se passe et du coup
je me sens un petit peu important et est
d'apporter ça mais ma mère frais etc
mais ouais non sinon joue pas non mais
ça les espoirs c'est vraiment que que le
monde hospitalier hospitalier prennent
un peu mieux en charge les enfants et
que défend c'est cool c'est que du
bonheur les clowns hôpitaux et tout mais
il ya des deux films avant en fait parce
que ça c'est quand on est dans des
hospitaliers hospitalisation longue mais
moi je me souviens enfin 7 mai pierre
traumatise l'hôpital où tu sens
littéralement [ __ ] de bouts de viande
ou t'as pas de monter juste assez la
dystrophie là où comme ça où on peut à
peine parler notamment le web plus ou
moins le numéro de ta chambre
voilà déjà et puis surtout toi tu
comprends pas parce que moi j'ai switché
février d'un coup et tu as un professeur
avec l'armada de deux internes que j'ai
développé une [ __ ] ten pour les
internautes se désolait mais où tu es
juste été un kids il est
9h30 du matin tu as une armada qui te
[ __ ] à poil qui décalages mais je m'en
parle de mu pourquoi vous montrer ma
table vous êtes 8
donc tu es vraiment juste déshumanisé en
fait elle prend dire on va se faire une
place sur lombez et je suis comprends
pas tu quand certains trucs comme ça tu
as deux infirmières qui comme ça depuis
au moins six ans tu expliques de rien tu
te retrouves à 3par chant et la
communication de lap dancing ce que tu
vois moi j'ai une amie qui était dans
une chambre avec une personne
enfin une autre enfant qui était vrai en
tennis mais tout ça vous voyez d'épinés
elle passe au bloc on le voit plus
revenir
les infirmières nous sommes allés partie
de ceux là et après on voit les parents
qui vont en sachant recherché cette
affaire tu as et qu'on communique rien
en fait et ça c'est horrible ça ça va
vraiment très très tristes donc à
s'écoule le côté chenni les toiles
enchantées tout ça mais vraiment faire
plus de fautes ricol d'entrer dans la
vie de malades entre safa vers gaza au
coeur merci beaucoup mais de rien
c'est nous